[Música]
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos para mais uma live. É
um prazer estar aqui com
vocês. E como é de prxa, nós vamos
iniciar agora respondendo as dúvidas do
formulário. Nós só temos quatro
dúvidas, porém uma delas é uma dúvida
composta, né, com várias
subperguntas, mas temos hoje
aqui um novo membro do nosso
grupo que nós vamos dar as boas-vindas.
Não sei o nome, não sei se é homem ou
mulher, tá como mãos cuidadoras aqui no
WhatsApp, mas vamos dar as
boas-vindas para essa pessoa que vai
depois se identificar.
Conforme vocês forem
entrando, por favor, dê o seu alô, dê o
seu boa noite para a gente poder ir
interagindo. Bem, houve um probleminha
no formulário que algumas perguntas que
foram feitas, foi invertido o nome da
pessoa e o nome da
pergunta. Dessa vez eu não vou fazer
aqui a apresentação das perguntas na
tela, mas eu vou ditando aqui para
vocês, tá?
Inclusive eu não tive tempo de fazer
aquele mini site que eu tava fazendo nas
lives
anteriores para apresentar para você as
perguntas, como se fosse uma
apresentação, né, de PowerPoint ou algo
que eu
valia. Bem, primeira pergunta é: Quais
são os suplementos essenciais pro homem
de 55? Eu já falei isso em posts no
Instagram, tem vídeo no
YouTube. Nós temos aí os suplementos,
né, os
nutrientes que mais tem deficiência de
modo geral em homens e mulheres. Então
vou comentar aqui os que são mais
comuns. Obviamente o ideal é sempre
estar fazendo exames para identificar
quais são naquela pessoa específica as
deficiências.
Porém, pensando no envelhecimento, né,
55 anos, nós temos que pensar em
nutrientes que dão suporte à saúde dos
ossos, dos músculos, cardiovascular, que
ainda é a causa mais comum de morte nos
homens, e também a questão cognitiva e
hormonal, né, considerando as mudanças
fisiológicas que ocorrem no
envelhecimento. Quais são as
deficiências mais comuns? Vitamina B12,
magnésio, vitamina D. Então, uma
suplementação que nós podemos pensar
para a pessoa em que está envelhecendo o
sexo masculino são as vitaminas do
complexo B, especialmente a vitamina
B12, metiocobalamina, o metiofolato que
o B9 e a piridoxina que a B6. Para que
que serve a B12? Ela é crucial pra
produção de glóbulos vermelhos, paraa
saúde neurológica também e para o
metabolismo da energia. E à medida que
nós vamos envelhecendo, a absorção de
B12 vai
piorando, a absorção da B12 natural vai
diminuindo. Então é uma das deficiências
mais comuns que eu vejo no
consultório. E a gente pode entrar com
metilcobalamina ou hidróxicobalamina de
500 microg, 1 mg por dia, né? E a
piridoxina, a vitamina B6, também é uma
deficiência muito comum para as pessoas
envelhecendo. E tem um problema que o
laboratório geralmente não dosa de
rotina, os planos não cobrem, então tem
essa dificuldade aí. Então, a B6 também
você pode estar tomando na faixa de 50
mg por dia na forma de peridoxal 5
fosfato. A vitamina D de dado é uma
deficiência extremamente comum porque as
pessoas não estão tomando sol, estão
sempre dentro de ambientes
fechados. E a D, ela tá envolvida em
mais de 20% do metabolismo humano, né?
Tá envolvido
em milhares de processos fisiológicos.
Quando se fala de vitamina D, todo mundo
lembra da absorção de cálcio, da
mobilização do cálcio pro osso. Mas a
vitamina D, muito mais do que isso. A
vitamina D, ela é muito importante para
o cérebro, por exemplo. Ela previne e
trata depressão. Ela é muito importante
pro sistema imune. Ela é muito
importante também para a saúde
muscular. Ela previne o câncer em
conjunto com a vitamina K2. Ela vai
ajudar na sistema de defesa imune, né?
Como vocês bem sabem, né? Quem passou aí
pela pandemia e tomou vitamina D e teve
os livros de vitamina D adequados, teve
muito
mais eh dificuldade de pegar o
vírus. Então, a vitamina D, ela tem que
estar no sangue
entre 50 e 70. Então é muito importante
você medir os seus níveis de vitamina D
para saber como eles estão. O outro
muito comum é o
magnésio. Magnésio é muito importante
pro sono, pra função muscular, pra saúde
neuronal do sistema nervoso central, pra
saúde do coração, também pro metabolismo
ósseo em equilíbrio com cálcio.
E a forma mais comum de repor o magnésio
na forma queelada é o magnésio glicinato
ou glicina ou
bisglicinato, que é uma formaquelada boa
para absorção. Nós temos também o
treonato, tem o dimalato, tem várias
maneiras aí taurato. Mas para
simplificar aqui, depois vocês podem
também assistir o meu vídeo que eu fiz
lá no YouTube sobre as 10 formas de
magnésio para complementar isso. Então,
magnésio é uma deficiência muito comum e
é difícil de ver nos exames. Então, essa
terceira deficiência muito comum à
medida que você for envelhecendo, OK?
Ômega-3 também pela dieta que nós temos,
uma dieta pobre, geralmente em gordura
saudável, com excesso de ômega-6 do óleo
de soja, óleo de milho, óleo canola e
girassol.
Ômega-3, que tem também nas carnes de
gado que pasta, tem na carne do frango
ou da galinha que cisca, mas como hoje
esses animais muitas vezes não tm
alimentação adequada, não comem a sua
alimentação ancestral, muitas vezes é
muito difícil obter omôme-3 dessas
carnes comuns. Então é importante você
ingerir peixes de mar, né, especialmente
de mar profundo ou algas que vão ter
ômega-3.
A linhaça também tá ômega-3, mas é uma
forma de
ômega-3 que tem a biodisponibilidade
inferior. Então existe sim uma enzima
que converte o ácido linolênico, né,
em as formas de ômega-3, que
é o docosa exenóico, que é o DH, o DHA,
e o e éosa pentenóico, que é o EPA. Só
que essa enzima ela é pouco ativa no
organismo. Então é mais interessante
suplementar-3, seja da fonte marinha de
peixes ou seja das
algas. Outra deficiência muito comum é a
do zinco. E o zinco é muito importante
também pra função imune, pra saúde
prostática, pra saúde sexual nos homens.
Então o zinco é muito importante pra
testosterona.
Então tem que tá dando uma olhada nos
níveis de zinco para poder suplementar
de uma maneira
adequada. A coenzima Q10 para quem toma
estatina, para quem
toma remédio para colesterol, é muito
importante que você utiliza a comenzima
Q10. Além de ser um antioxidante, que
ajuda na saúde cardiovascular, tem ação
de regular a pressão arterial, tem ação
de aumentar a energia celular, pode
ajudar a tratar enxaqueca, pode ajudar a
tratar
fibromialgia. Então tem várias ações
positivas da coenzima Q10.
A taurina é um aminoácido muito
importante também, que geralmente se
você tem uma dieta adequada não vai ter
deficiência de taurina. Porém, muitas
pessoas hoje estão esgotadas
fisicamente, mentalmente. Muitas
pessoas tem a questão do burnout e a
taurina é muito boa para ajudar no
sistema nervoso central de pessoas que
estão esgotadas, que estão estressadas,
que estão dormindo mal. E a taurina,
além de ser excelente para o sistema
nervoso central, ela é muito boa pro
coração, ela é muito boa para ajudar na
qualidade do sono e ela é muito boa na
saúde cerebral. Boa noite, Eloía, muito
bem-vinda. Obrigado por tá participando
da live. Até agora só Eloía deu um alô,
pessoal. Tem mais alguém acompanhando ao
vivo? Por favor, não sejam tímidos. dê o
seu boa noite, dê o seu olá, porque às
vezes eu sinto que é como se eu tivesse
falando sozinho
aqui. Próximo ponto aqui, nos últimos
anos para cá passou a ser cada vez mais
claro que o ácido hialurônico e o
colágeno são interessantes para prevenir
o envelhecimento. E o colágeno, além de
ser importante pro intestino, ser
importante pro sistema imune, é uma
fonte de glicina que vai ajudar na saúde
da pele. Então, junto com o ácido
hialurônico é muito bom para ajudar que
a pele envelheça mais lentamente. Também
vai ser útil pros ossos, paraas
articulações, para ajudar a evitar a
perda de tôus muscular e melhorar a
elasticidade da pele. OK? E aí, se você
tá fazendo atividade física, também é
muito interessante estar utilizando
proteínas, as várias fontes de proteínas
que nós temos aí suplementares, o
protein, a proteina da arivilha, do
arroz, do câno, da albumina do ovo, o
próprio colágeno que eu já comentei
também interessante junto com a creatina
para ajudar na atividade física. E se
esse homem acima de 55 tiver sintomas
prostáticos, é interessante usar o sol
pometo, o pig africano, a tiga de oica,
o betacitosterol, o licopeno paraa saúde
prostática. Isso vai ser bem
interessante. E algumas pessoas vão
também se beneficiar com o uso de
tocotrieno e tocoferoid, né? As
vitaminas da família E são antioxidantes
importantes para ajudar no
envelhecimento, né? Então é possível,
né, em muitos casos, tomar um
polivitamínico ou
multivitamínico, né, ajudando a
preencher lacunas nutricionais, de
preferência auxiliado aí por exames, que
vai então
tá fornecendo essas vitaminas do
complexo B que eu comentei também, a
vitamina D de dado, a vitamina K2, é o
próprio zinco que eu comentei, o próprio
magnésio e se for necessário o Celên
Se for necessári as vitaminas A, que tem
que ser vistas em exame de sangue, para
vitamina A pode dar
hipervitaminose. E também no exame de
sangue, se tiver deficiência de C, tomar
também a vitamina C junto com esse
complexo
vitamínico. OK? Então essa é um apanhado
geral para responder essa pergunta. Boa
noite, Antônio Renato. Boa noite,
Ricardo Abreu. Obrigado pelo comentário,
Ricardo Abreu. Você que é o das mãos
cuidadoras ou o ou que
você colocou a mensagem aqui ou você não
é o mãos cuidadoras?
Agradeço aí pelo seu
comentário. Bem, a próxima
pergunta, eh, se uma pessoa estiver
preste a ter um AVC ou infarto, pera,
deixa eu colocar isso aqui. Deixa eu
colocar com uma mensagem
aqui e aí eu
apresento aqui. pergunta aí, se a pessoa
tiver prestes a ter um AVC ou infarto e
ela não souber disso, mas se ela ficar
hidratada dias
antes de forma constante e diminuir os
alimentos perigosos, ela pode evitar
ambas as doenças ou ao menos uma delas?
Deixa eu mostrar
aqui como a hidratação pode evitar você
falou em um vídeo que poderia. Vamos lá.
A hidratação adequada é sim um dos
passos essenciais para evitar coágulos
sanguíneos. Prevenção, pessoal,
prevenção de
coágulos. Os coágulos são fatores
críticos pro AVC isquêmico, que é o
acidente vascular cerebral, e também
para o infarto agudo miocárdio, porque
entope as artérias, tanto no coração
quanto no cérebro. Existe também o AVC
hemorrágico, que é outro mecanismo,
geralmente é por aumento de pressão
arterial súbita que explode a artéria e
extravasa sangue, mas a maioria dos AVCs
são isquêmicos, tá? que são por
entupimento. Tem estudos científicos,
então, que comprovam essa questão da
hidratação. Eles mostram que a ingestão
de pelo menos cinco a seis copos de água
por dia, que vai dar por volta de 2 L,
pode reduzir em até 53% o risco de AVC,
porque a desidratação torna um sangue
mais espesso, mais grosso, mais viscoso
e isso facilita a formação de trombos
que vão
obstruir esses territórios do cérebro ou
das coronárias no
coração. Além disso, a hidratação, ela
ajuda a manter a pressão arterial sob
controle, vai melhorar a fluidez do
sangue e tanto essa pressão arterial
controlada quanto a a fluidez do sangue
controlado são fatores que vão evitar
você de ter o AVC e o
infarto. E por outro lado, a
desidratação, contrário disso, aumenta a
pressão arterial, aumenta o risco de
obstruções vasculares e eleva as chances
de eventos cardiovasculares
graves. Boa noite, Alice Vogel, seja
muito bem-vinda à nossa live.
Então, quanto à alimentação, reduzir o
consumo de alimentos perigosos são os
alimentos ultraprocessados, biscoito,
bolacha, refrigerante, bolo, torta, fast
food, embutidos, carnes processadas.
Isso também diminui o risco de infarto
em AVC, porque esses alimentos aumentam
a pressão arterial devido ao sal
refinado e os aditivos que eles colocam
nesses alimentos. E por sua vez, isso
promove a formação de placa nas
artérias.
Então, uma dieta saudável, com alimentos
naturais não processados, com frutas sem
exagero de frutose, vegetais, grãos
integrais, leguminosa, né, os feijões,
fava, grão de
bico, peixes ricos em
ômega-3, nozes e castanhas em macadâmia,
azeite de
oliva, tudo isso ajuda a controlar, né,
as gorduras do sangue, os triglicérides,
né, equilibrar o HDL colesterol também
na pressão arterial também reduzindo
inação, então prevenindo essas doenças
cardiovasculares. Portanto, mesmo que a
pessoa não saiba que está prestes a ter
um AVC infarto, manter hidratado de
forma constante, reduzindo os alimentos
perigosos, pode sim ajudar a prevenir
pelo menos um desses eventos,
especialmente ao melhorar essa fluidez
do sangue, tornando esse sangue mais
fluido, menos espesso. e evitando a
formação de coágulos, além de reduzir os
fatores de risco como hipertensão
arterial e
aterosclerose. Então, óbvio que a
hidratação não é uma garantia absoluta,
é uma medida simples, porém não é
milagrosa,
OK? E temos estudos comprovando
isso. Próxima pergunta aqui também, a
pergunta é enorme, tá? Não vai caber na
na tela aqui. Vamos ver se a gente
consegue fazer em partes aqui.
Ã, isso aqui acho que não vai caber nem
numa na tela aqui. Vamos tentar ver se
vai
caber. Não, não cobe. Vamos
lá. Na visão da medicina integrativa, a
morte cerebral pode ser revertida. Você
como médico já viu pessoas que haviam
sido desenganadas e voltaram?
Esses casos que aconteceram nos Estados
Unidos de um homem
que teve overdose e foi declarado morto
e quando estavam levando ele paraa sala
de extração de órgãos, ele, graças a
Deus
reviveu. Aí a pergunta continua. Eh,
vamos lá.
E uma possibilidade, acha que se as
famílias quisessem manter os aparelhos,
elas deveriam ter esse
direito? Na legislação brasileira, se a
se a família tiver condições
financeiras, podem transferir
para hospital particular e manter outros
médicos aí. Não entendi. Aí acho que
ficou truncado aí. Acho que ele tá
querendo dizer de outros médicos
acompanharem de fora, né, do hospital.
Desligar a força. Você como médico acha
que existe muita maracutaia no SUS e
pessoas podem estar sendo mortas por
mafiosos? Essa história do mafioso, eu
não sei se eu entendi bem, mas vamos lá,
vamos tentar responder essa pergunta. O
que que é a morte encefálica? Como é que
ela é definida?
é a perda irreversível das funções
cerebrais e isso inclui a região do
tronco
cerebral que tá na base do crânio e
também dos hemisférios direito e
esquerdo. E isso daí é estabelecido, é
definido pelo Conselho Federal de
Medicina.
dentro da medicina funcional
integrativa, essa condição também
entendida como ponto final biológico. Aí
a gente não vai entrar aqui em critérios
religiosos ou da crença de cada um, tá?
Mas da questão biológica seria o ponto
final,
sim. Ah, ainda não há evidências
científicas robustas que sustentem uma
reversibilidade de morte cerebral, tá?
Desde que esse diagnóstico tenha sido
feito com protocolos rigorosos, pode ser
que haja
falhas. Então, vamos falar um pouquinho
sobre esses casos de reversão e
possíveis erros
diagnósticos. Tem relatos aí de
pacientes que recuperaram funções após o
diagnóstico inicial de morte cerebral,
como é o caso da Naiara Cristina
Patracão e do Thomas Hoover nos Estados
Unidos. Então, Anayar no Brasil e o
Thomas Hoover nos Estados Unidos.
Geralmente isso foi atribuído a erro na
aplicação do protocolo de morte cerebral
ou uma interpretação prematura desses
exames. No caso brasileiro, o que foi
apurado, tá? Eu não acompanhei
pessoalmente esse caso, é que a paciente
apresentou reflexos após a redução do
edema cerebral, o que levou a revisar o
diagnóstico. OK? Então, provavelmente
sinais estavam muito fracos, foi
interpretado como morte cerebral, mas a
partir do momento que reduziu o edema,
os sinais ficaram mais fortes e o
critério de morte cerebral não
foi cumprido. Então, nos Estados Unidos,
o Hoover foi declarado morto sem
confirmação adequada, né? também essa
informação que podemos apurar, eu não
acompanhei o caso
pessoalmente, destacando então que houve
falhas graves nesse processo. Então
esses casos, até onde eu sei, são
exceções das exceções, tá? Isso não
altera o consenso médico de morte
cerebral que considera que a morte
encefálica é irreversível quando feito o
diagnóstico
adequado. falando sobre direitos aí das
famílias, legislação brasileira no
Brasil, depois que existe a confirmação
de morte encefálica por dois médicos, a
legislação manda que sejam dois médicos
através tanto do traçado
eletroencefalograma, como por exames
clínicos e outros exames complementares.
Depois desse diagnóstico, não haveria a
obrigatoriedade de manutenção de
aparelhos, mesmo em hospitais
particulares. OK? Aí teria que ser uma
conversa entre a família e a equipe
médica para decidir manter esse aparelho
ligado aí mais um dia que seja, talvez
para você ter uma triconfirmação, uma
quatreconfirmação, ou seja, não sei mais
se dois médicos, mas três ou quatro
médicos, de que houve de fato essa morte
cerebral.
Em se tratando de legislação, é isso que
eu tô te falando, não existe a
obrigatoriedade da equipe hospitalar
maner de manter esses equipamentos
funcionando depois da confirmação por
dois médicos na morte cerebral. Então o
CFM, Conselho Federal, determina o
desligamento dos
equipamentos, exceto em caso de doação
de órgãos, né, que vai manter ligado até
conseguir fazer a retirada dos órgãos.
Porém tem casos já registrados, né?
Existe jurisprudência de famílias que
buscaram liminares judiciais para
contestar o diagnóstico. Aconteceu isso
em Rondônia, por exemplo, onde um pai
impediu o desligamento até nova
avaliação. Então, o fato de você
transferir para outro hospital, para
outra instituição, isso não garante a
continuidade do suporte vital se o
diagnóstico for mantido. Então, é uma
questão de conversa da equipe médica com
a família. Em alguns casos, se não
houver concordância, a família pode
entrar com uma ação judicial, tá? Em
relação a denúncias de irregularidades
no SUS, há registros históricos de
práticas éticas
questionáveis, como foi o caso da médica
Virgínia Soares de Souza, no Paraná, em
2013. Isso aí tem mais de 10 anos. e ela
foi acusada de desligar respiradores de
pacientes no SUS para liberar
leito, né? Então, teve testemunhas que
relataram que essa médica tinha uma
diferenciação
lamentavelmente no tratamento se eram
pacientes do SUS ou
particulares, tá? Então, tem essas
absurdos. O Brasil vocês sabem que não é
para amadores, vão ter absurdos, mas
também acontece absurdo de outras partes
do mundo, OK?
Até onde eu sei, esses casos aí são
isolados e não refletem uma realidade do
sistema como um todo.
OK? Falando aqui de perspectivas
futuras, existem pesquisas preliminares,
como é o caso aí da Universidade Yale, e
que eles estão testando aí reanimação de
tecidos em bos.
Então isso tá muito no início ainda, mas
pode significar um avanço aí nos
próximos 20 ou 30 anos, avanço
tecnológico, poderia alterar esse
paradigmas aí de diagnóstico de morte
encefálica, mas isso tá muito longe da
realidade ainda e até o momento eu não
tenho aplicação clínica em humanos para
reversão de morte
cefálica, ok?
Então, resumindo, morte cefálica
continua sendo esse critério, dois
médicos diferentes para confirmar o
diagnóstico. Esses protocolos são
considerados rígidos. Mesmo assim, é
óbvio que de vez em quando vai ter
uma situação aí de erro, uma situação
anômala. Caso de recuperação geralmente
acontecem envolvendo falhas
diagnósticas.
E a legislação brasileira, ela prioriza
a confirmação técnica sobre a vontade
familiar, mas nada impede da família
entrar com ação judicial,
tá? Denúncias de má conduta vão existir,
tá? Mas você pode acionar a justiça para
investigar e punir quando
comprovado. Bem, vamos paraa próxima
pergunta
aqui. Vou colocar na tela para vocês
aqui. Eu acho que vai ter que ser em
duas vezes também.
Antes da pandemia, os médicos tinham uma
noção de que vacina tinha que ter no
mínimo 10 anos de testes. Depois da
pandemia, todos esqueceram isso e
aceitaram vacina em 12
meses. Isso é verdade? Como médico, você
achou essas mudanças repentinas
estranhas? Como ficou você no meio disso
tudo? Bem, quem fez essa pergunta?
Deixa eu ver quem
foi. Não tô localizando aqui, mas tudo
bem. Vamos
lá. Eu vou falar para vocês o qual que é
a visão oficial e qual que é a minha
visão de vários outros médicos que
trabalham na medicina funcional, tá?
antes da pandemia de
C19, é verdade que o desenvolvimento de
vacinas levava entre 5 a 10 anos, até
mais do que isso, dependendo do caso. E,
óbvio, isso era para garantir segurança
e eficácia por meio de testes
pré-clínicos e também testes clínicos
rigorosos, né? Tinha fase um, fase dois,
fase
três. Isso incluía também os processos
regulatórios de produção de lag escala.
Essa longa duração era muito necessária
e
prudente para fazer uma avaliação
cuidadosa. E existia legislação que
garantia o intervalo entre as fases para
análise dos dados de segurança e de
imunogen com a situação da C19. Houve
uma mudança radical nesse cenário. Aí eu
vou apresentar para vocês primeiro a
visão oficial e a visão minha. como eu
disse e de vários
colegas. Segundo a visão oficial, né, as
vacinas contra C19 foram desenvolvidas e
aprovadas em tempo recorde, muitas vezes
em menos de 12
meses. E eles justificam que isso não é
uma situação
apressada ou que não houve
flexibilização de
padrões. OK? Por que que eles justificam
isso?
Porque a plataforma que foi utilizada
tecnológica para introduzir o RNA
mensageiro, né, vacina da Pfizer e da
Moderna e do adenovírus modificado, que
era da
Astrazênica, supostamente já vinham
sendo desenvolvidos para outras doenças
há mais de uma década, tá? Essa a
primeira
justificativa. E aí eles falam também
que houve uma situação de sobreposição
das fases clínicas. Em vez de esperar o
térmico completo da fase
dois, eles fizeram aí uma situação de
juntar as fases 1, 2 e três. Na verdade,
tá comprovado que a fase três não foi
concluída, tá? Na verdade, a gente pode
considerar que foram soltas esses
produtos no
mercado com a fase dois e não a fase
três concluída. Então eles justificam
que eles juntaram as fases, elas foram
parcialmente combinadas e isso teria
acelerado a coleta e análise de
dados. E aí outra justificativa é que
houve um financiamento global e uma
colaboração internacional que permitiu
que múltiplos centros realizassem testes
simultâneos. Então haveria esse ganho aí
devido a múltiplos centros trabalhar em
conjunto, OK?
E eles admitem que houve uma produção
antecipada dos lotes antes da aprovação
final, que não aconteceu de fato porque
foi acelerado esse processo, para que
tivessem esses produtos disponíveis
imediatamente após autorização
emergencial. Veja que até as explicações
são um pouco suspeitas, não sei se vocês
concordam comigo, tá? Vamos tentar
analisar a situação da maneira mais
imparcial possível, né? sem paixões, não
te parece justificativas um pouco
estranhas, né?
E outra jusificativa, altas taxas de
infecção
facilitaram a avaliação rápida da
eficácia dos produtos, pois o número de
casos em grupos controle, né, e também o
número de casos em grupo de pessoas que
tomaram permitiu análise estatísticas
robustas em curto prazo. Também me acho
isso um um argumento muito fraco. OK.
E aí,
complementando as argumentações
oficiais, as agências reguladoras
mantiveram rigorosos critérios de
avaliação, exigindo evidências claras de
segurança e eficácia antes da aprovação
emergencial. Não concordo com isso, OK?
E estariam ainda monitorando os efeitos
adversos após a liberação. OK?
Agora vou falar a minha visão, tá
pessoal? E de várias outras
pessoas. Atropelaram o processo devido
ao pânico. Então, para poder ter essa
aprovação em tempo recorde com uma
tecnologia não
testada, isso só foi possível porque
houve uma pressão muito grande do
público. E como é que foi gerada essa
pressão do público? através do pânico. A
mídia fez um trabalho muito intenso de
fomentar o pânico nas pessoas e então as
pessoas eh também passaram a acreditar
que não existiam outra solução a não ser
essas soluções aí. OK? Então isso foi o
que permitiu os políticos a fazer o que
fizeram durante aquele período, tá?
Então, eu mesmo, não sei se a pessoa que
fez a pergunta sabe, mas eu fiz muitos
vídeos durante esse período alertando as
pessoas e
sofri, né, um bac muito grande por conta
desse meu posicionamento. Até hoje eu
sofro as consequências dessa posição que
eu tive durante o
período. É, foi um período muito
estranho pro canal do YouTube esse
período de 2020 até
2023, porque o canal cresceu muito, mas
por outro lado eu sofri vários strikes
da
plataforma. E o que acontece hoje, nos
últimos dois anos, o canal sofreu muito
com Shadow B, a ponto de eu desanimar
muito em relação à produção de vídeos,
porque antes um vídeo que tinha a média
de 30.000 visualizações e tinha vários
vídeos que passavam de 100.000 1000
visualizações, alguns passavam de
500.000 e até 1 milhão. Eu passei a ter
eh 1000, 2000, 3.000 visualizações por
vídeo, tá? Então, foi essa razão que
esse ano vocês praticamente estão vendo
que eu tô me dedicando a vocês do grupo
fechado e tô produzindo muito pouco
vídeo esse
ano, OK?
E hoje nós sabemos que tem várias
consequências aí desse período de
aprovação acelerado. Nós estamos vendo
muitas tromboses, nós estamos vendo
muito AVCs, nós estamos vendo muito
infarto, nós estamos vendo muitos casos
de câncer tubo, disfunção do sistema
imune com doenças autoimunes. Nós
estamos vendo morte súbita em jovem,
estamos vendo criança ficando doente com
desbiose, que coisa que não existia
antes. Estamos vendo queda da
fertilidade masculina e feminina.
Estamos vendo aumento de doenças
ginecológicas. Tudo isso tá acontecendo
devido aos fatos que vêm acontecendo
desde 2020,
seja a doença, seja a solução da doença.
Os dois produzem proteína spike, está
gerando adoecimento da população, tá?
Fora a tecnologia de RNA mensageiro que
está modificando geneticamente as
pessoas, tá? Eu sei que é um tema muito
polêmico, as pessoas ficam extremamente
reativas quando a gente conversa sobre
isso, mas eu estou vendo na prática as
consequências,
tá? Mas se vocês quiserem saber mais
sobre isso, vocês vão ter que ir lá no
Rumble usar VPN, porque o nosso STF
bloqueou o Rumble no Brasil. Os vídeos
que estavam no YouTube eu tive que jogar
do Rumble, mas o que está no Rumble hoje
não tá acessível sem VPN, tá? Tem que
entrar através de VPN.
Bem, vamos para pro próxima pergunta
aqui, tá? Temos
mais quatro perguntas aí que pessoal fez
agora. Manter níveis normais de vitamina
D previne todos os tipos de câncer? Não,
infelizmente não. Sono de sono sol. O
que que é sono sol? Até 9 horas é bom
para dormir rápido de noite. Eu acho. Tá
querendo dizer se o sol até às 9 horas
da manhã ajuda no sono. É isso que a
pergunta.
Ô Antônio Renato, você tá aí ao
vivo? Não estou vendo o Antônio Renato
aqui, mas mas como ele mandou agora às
7:41, tô imaginando que ele tá
acompanhando a live, tá?
Eh, não sei se eu entendi a sua
pergunta. Se você puder se
manifestar, eu vou deixar para depois
então responder isso daí, tá? Se você
puder, só explicar para mim se você tá
falando do sol das 9 horas da manhã.
Deixa parte para a
próxima. Entre ser viciado em biscoitos
todos os dias e carboidratos e a dieta
cetogênica, qual é o melhor para
prevenir o câncer?
Bem, não sei se eu entendi essa pergunta
também, tá um pouco mal formulada aqui.
Ser viciado em biscoitos é péssimo, né,
obviamente,
né? Então, para você fazer dieta
cetogênica, você necessariamente vai ter
que parar de comer esses biscoitos, tá?
E sim, a dieta cetogênica é um dos
melhores métodos para prevenir câncer,
mas eu já expliquei aqui em outros
vídeos que existem cânceres, é a
minoria, mas existem que podem se
alimentar de derivado de gordura, tá?
Mas a maioria dos cânceres respeitam
aquele princípio de Warberg, que é a
glicólise anaeróbica, né? Então, se você
cortar o fornecimento de
glicose, o câncer vai ter muita
dificuldade de se manter, porque ele não
faz uso de outros metabólitos, como é o
caso da gordura ou de aminoácido. Mas
isso existe câncer sim que consegue usar
a gordura como fonte de energia,
conforme a gente conversou nas lives
anteriores, tá?
Então sim, a dieta citogênica é muito
importante para prevenir o
câncer e obviamente muitas pessoas não
consegue fazer essa dieta por muito
tempo, mas se você conseguir fazer, por
exemplo, 6 meses cetogênica, se meses de
local e ficar alternando também é um
recurso
interessante. Voltando a pergunta aqui
do Antônio
Renato, ele confirmou aqui que tava
falando do sol da manhã,
né? Já respondi aqui, a vitamina D não
previne todos os tipos de câncer. A D e
a K2, elas têm uma ação anticâncer
porque regula o sistema imune, né? porém
não vai conseguir resolver todos os
cânceres. OK?
Bem, quanto ao sono, dormir até 9 horas
por dia, eh, vai
ser uma coisa que vai variar de pessoa
para pessoa. Tem gente que não precisa
de 9 horas de sono, tem pessoas que com
6, 7 horas vai tá bem, mas tem gente que
precisa de 9 horas de sono. Então, sono
de qualidade vai ser muito bom pro
sistema imune e vai também ajudar a
prevenir o câncer em modo geral. OK?
O sono é muito importante para restaurar
tecidos, ajudar no crescimento muscular,
na ciêntese proteica, na regulação
hormonal. Então é bem importante o sono
adequado. Pode variar de 7 a 9 horas por
noite e para algumas pessoas aceitavam 6
horas.
E o sol, na verdade, você pode tomar o
sol desde da manhã cedo até o meio-dia,
contanto que você não passe muito do,
dependendo da cor da sua pele. Se você
tiver a cor muito clara, é melhor ficar
15 minutos exposto ao sol. E se você
tiver a pele mais escura, você pode
ficar até 1 hora no sol. Mas além disso,
eu não recomendo que pode ter aí
problemas de pele relacionado a alguns
tipos de câncer de pele,
tá?
Ahã. Antônio Renato tá se manifestando
aqui. E o seos e se o sol após nove
também pode ajudar no sono da noite?
Pode ajudar sim.
Não é só o só antes das 9, não. Depois
das 9 também pode ajudar no
sono. Também temos mais uma pergunta
aqui. Minha esposa tem Hashimoto e é
lactante. Tem algum impacto em tomar o,
eu acho que quis dizer que LDN, né?
Tá escrito LND, mas deve ser o
LDN. Tem algum vídeo para membros
falando sobre os exames laboratoriais
para identificação do Hashimoto e uma
possível remissão? Bem, os exames para
identificar Hashimoto são os anticorpos,
né? Antitpo e
antitiroglobulina, OK? Então isso
independente, isso tem vídeo no canal
sim, mas não necessariamente vídeo no na
parte fechada, até na parte aberta
mesmo, OK?
O LDN eu uso muito para tratamento do
Rashimoto porque axção de baixa dosagem
é um imunomodulador muito bom, tá? Só
que tem outras coisas que ajuda a baixar
os anticorpos, é o caso selênio e é o
caso da mediformamina em em baixas
doses. Eles ajudam a baixar os
anticorpos do rachimoto, tá?
E tem também o óleo essencial de cominho
preto que
ajuda. Em relação o diagnóstico do
Hashimoto, além dos anticorpos, é
importante você ver o hipotiroidismo
através da medida do T3 livre, T4 L, TSH
e também ultrassom de tireoide para
avaliar se essa tireoideode está
inflamada ou se ela tem nódulos. OK?
Temos mais uma pergunta
aqui. O jejum tem o poder de prevenir
todos os tipos de câncer e eliminar
células cancerígenas, independentemente
se o câncer se alimenta de gordura e
carboidratos, o jejum ele vai ajudar a
prevenir, mas infelizmente ele não vai
eliminar todas as células cancerígenas,
porque tem outros fatores que podem eh
fazer essas células cancerígenas
surgirem, tá? Então, não existe uma
prevenção única, tá, para câncer,
pessoal. Você tem que, por exemplo, HPV,
que é um câncer de col uterino, tá
associado ao câncer de col
uterino, você tem que eliminar esse
vírus do organismo e eliminar as lesões
pré-cancerígenas que esse vírus provoca,
tá? Então, mesmo que a pessoa faça
jejum, por exemplo, ela não vai prevenir
um câncer de coluterino se ela não tiver
livre desse vírus do HPV, tá? É um
exemplo que eu tô dando para você aí, no
caso, né?
Então, jejum a dieta cetogênica vão
ajudar na maioria dos cânceres, mas eles
não são uma saída definitiva para todo
mundo, tá?
Ahã. Ah, sim. Pergunta. Tem um
comentário aqui do Antônio
Renato. Obrigado pelo comentário. Antôio
Renato, você já disse que faz protocolo
de detox, mas não sabe se eles funcionam
para OK. Você já tem alguma ideia de
detox? Não, eu faço um protocolo,
inclusive eu faço isso até antes do dos
debalos, né? O pessoal fala muito aí do
protocolo do Zebalos, porque Zé Balos
ficou extremamente famoso aí na
pandemia, né? Mas esse procolo do Zé
Balos, ele não tirou da cabeça dele, ele
tirou do FCC, né? Então eu comecei a
fazer esse detox até mesmo antes do
Zebalo comentar sobre isso, porque ele
ele tirou da mesma fonte que
eu, entendeu?
Bem, estamos indo agora para 44 minutos
de live.
Novamente eu dou as boas-vindas, tá,
para o Ricardo Abril, que tá agora
fazendo parte do nosso grupo. Muito
obrigado, Ricardo, por você fazer parte
da nossa
comunidade e espero poder ajudar da
melhor forma possível aí nas nossas
lives semanais e também você vai ter
muita oportunidade aí de estar
interagindo com o nosso grupo que é
muito bom, é um grupo que interage
bastante na no WhatsApp, troca muitas
informações de saúde aí bastante úteis.
Temos mais perguntas ao vivo,
pessoal? Tem algum assunto que vocês
queiram que eu
comente? Tá aqui um comentário da Eloía.
Muito obrigado, Eloía, pelo seu
comentário. Quais são as perspectivas de
limpar RNA mensageiro? Bem, não é bem
limpar RNA mensageiro, tá? O que
acontece, tá? as soluções aí. Eu tô
tentando evitar de usar as palavras,
pessoal, porque mesmo sendo uma live
fechada, eu tive uma vez um vídeo que eu
coloquei e que foi apagado pelo pela
plataforma, tá? Então eu vou evitar de
falar algumas palavras aqui. Então a
solução aí, certo, eh, imunológica que
tinha o RNA
mensageiro foi desenvolvido com uma
modificação da base nitrogenada desse
RNA que foi trocado a oracila dele por
uma base nutrogenada
equivalente e que paraa estabilização
dessa molécula. Então teve essa
modificação, teve a questão do
polietilino glicol, que era para
estabilizar as microesferas, né, de
gordura onde se RNA estava
inserido. E aí tem a questão de que já
existe estudos mostrando que esse RNA
mensageiro está sofrendo ação de
transcriptase reversa e tá sendo
transformado em DNA incorporado no
organismo das pessoas, tá?
Então já tá comprovado que não é
verdade, que eles estavam alegando que
depois da injeção do
deloide, aquele RNA ficava só algumas
semanas e era eliminado pelo organismo.
Isso já tá comprovado que não é verdade,
tá?
Ã, então o detox nós estamos fazendo, na
verdade é para o a proteína spike, não
necessariamente para o RNA mensageiro,
OK?
Então, nem não se sabe ainda se existe
um jeito de evitar esse na mensageiro
ser transformado em DNA no corpo das
pessoas que
tomaram. O que a gente pode fazer para
ajudar as pessoas é dar eh substâncias
que bloqueiam, tá, o a spike, que é o
caso do NAC,
nquinase, é o caso dos probióticos, é o
caso da ivemectina, OK?
Então, eh, até onde eu sei, a gente não
tem uma solução específica para as
partículas de RNA
mensageiro. Não conheço uma saída
específica para esse caso.
Aí bem, a Alice Volger tá perguntando
sobre pernas inquietas durante o
sono. Vamos lá.
Tem algum uma algum um aspecto
específico? Você quer saber, ô Alice? Ou
é um em geral mesmo? Você quer saber?
Bem, vamos lá até você responder, deixa
eu começar aqui. É um distúrbio
neurológico, acontece durante o sono e
que a pessoa que tem isso daí tem uma
necessidade
irresistível de movimentar as pernas.
Isso é geralmente acompanhado por
sensação desconfortável nas nos membros
inferiores, né? Formigamento, fisgada,
queimação, pontada. OK?
e pode aparecer tanto à noite quanto em
momentos de
repouso. E a pessoa que tem esse
problema, ela tem dificuldade até
desescrever o que ela tá sentindo,
né? E geralmente o desconforto melhora
parcialmente quando a pessoa mexe as
pernas. Isso atrapalha muito o
sono. E as pessoas que tendem esse
problema, elas vão ter muita dificuldade
de relaxar e pegar no sono de maneira
adequada. Então isso leva vários
despertares
frequentes e o sono não
reparador. E tá acompanhado também com
movimentos involuntários das pernas,
né? A causa exata não é conhecida.
Acredita-se que tem um componente
neurológico que envolve aí desequilíbrio
de dopamina de neurotransmissor, que
você sabe que tá relacionado à sensação
de bem-estar e de recompensa. E esse
neurotransmissor também regula a
atividade muscular. Então, acredita-se
que fatores genéticos,
gravidez, anemia com deficiência de
ferro aumente, né, a chance da pessoa
ter esse problema. E também pessoas que
têm insufícia renal ou que consomem de
maneira exagerada a cafeína ou que fumem
bastante, isso agrave o
problema. Que que geralmente os
neurologistas passam para
isso? Geralmente eles passam gabapentina
e pregabalina, tá? São os remédios mais
comuns que eles passam. Mas existe
também o uso de
antipsicóticos como uma terceira opção.
Aí dentro da
medicina integrativa ou medicina
funcional, a gente tem aí vários
tratamentos que podem ajudar, tá?
Um deles é o magnésio. Outro tratamento
desses é o extrato de
cannabis. Como eu falei na medicina
ortodoxa, geralmente é usado cavapentina
e pregabalina. E em segundo plano
antipsicótico que é chamado
pramipexol, ok?
Em alguns casos também é utilizado o
Levodopa, que é o remédio para Paxon,
mas é um remédio que tem muito problema
de uso prolongado, então eu acho que tem
que ser a quarta opção aí,
OK? Se a pessoa que tem a perna inquieta
tiver deficiência de ferro, a
suplementação de ferro ajuda bastante,
melhora bastante os
sintomas. A gente também se preocupa em
repor vitamina D de dado, em repor
magnésio, em repor complexo B.
Vitamina C, vitamina E, corta cafeína,
corta álcool, corta tabaco, fazera,
relaxamento,
meditação,
alongamentos, a atividade física também
ajuda demais, compressa quente alternada
com compressa fria, massagem ajuda, OK?
Alguns casos pode ser até utilizar
terapia de estimulação elétrica nervosa
transcutânea. Pessoas podem utilizar
também a luz infravermelha, né, ou LED,
né, pode utilizar a luz pulsada, também
pode ajudar bastante. A estimulação
magnética transcraniana também é um
tratamento viável, tá?
e fazer uma dieta
antiinflamatória. Alguns casos também
pode ser utilizado fitoterapia com uso
do ervo de São João, né, o
hipérico, que ele é um antidepressivo
natural e pode aumentar os níveis de
dopamina, tá relacionado ao problema.
Beleza? Diz aí, Alice, se foi o
suficiente para você, tá?
O Antônio Renato tá dizendo aqui:
"Obrigado, doutor, que Deus ele abençoe
sua família". Obrigado, querido.
Obrigado. Tudo bem, Alice? Você entendeu
a explicação? Tem alguma coisa que não
ficou clara para
você? De nada.
Tá de nada.
Bem, pessoal, então vou encerrar a live
por agora, tá bom? E a gente se fala na
semana que vem. E eu acho que eu vou
trazer artigos, né? Tem algumas semanas
que eu não trago artigos para vocês. Um
abraço, um beijo no coração de vocês.
Até a
próxima.
Eu que agradeço.